baby it's cold outside
which means it's lovely weather to
snuggle up with your Valentine and sip
some instant hot chocolate
so today's Swiss mission is to find out
what's inside that perfect packet of
powder
starting with pulverized cocoa which
gives the drink its distinctive flavor
at least once the extracts natural
bitterness has been Sweden substantially
with sucralose a lower calorie
derivative of sucrose that adds less
bulk to packaging and your belly while
also tasting up to a thousand times
sweeter than common table sugar and
because cocoa is nearly impossible to
dissolve in its natural state the powder
also requires a quick soak in alkali
salts which react with fatty acids in
the extract to boost its solubility
while sodium element is silicate a
component used to strengthen smartphone
screens traps moisture so the only lumps
in the mix are the very best part of hot
chocolate that's right marshmallows made
from gelatin and cornstarch with a dash
of sodium hexametaphosphate for added
fluff and finally vegetable oils and
dairy products solids are added to the
mix providing some of the creaminess
you'd get if you made your hot chocolate
with actual milk instead of boiling
water which instantly transforms a
science lab full of ingredients into a
piping hot cup of relief from all the
frozen h2o outside
feeling wide yet subscribe